يجب دفع التعويضات عن تجارة الرقيق
[موسيقى] لقد حان
الوقت للاعتراف علنًا بأن
معظم أوروبا والولايات المتحدة
قد تم بناؤها من الثروة الهائلة التي تم
حصادها من العرق والدموع والدماء
والأهوال في تجارة الرقيق عبر المحيط الأطلسي وقرون
الاستغلال الاستعماري
[موسيقى] لقد
طال انتظار الوقت
لتصحيح الظلم الذي طال أمده
والذي يمثله الهيكل والتكوين الحالي
لمجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة بالنسبة
للأمم الأفريقية.
[موسيقى]
لا نريد أن نكون ندبة على ضمير أي شخص
ولكننا لا نستطيع
ذلك.  لا ينبغي للعالم أن يتظاهر
بأن الظروف الاقتصادية والاجتماعية الحالية
في أفريقيا لا علاقة لها
بالمظالم التاريخية التي تشهدها
هياكل العالم.
ربما ينبغي لنا أيضًا أن نعترف بأنه لا
يمكن أن يكون من السهل بناء
مجتمعات واثقة ومزدهرة من الدول التي  لقرون
عديدة،
نهبت مواردهم الطبيعية وتم
المتاجرة بشعوبهم كسلع